when you have actors who know their
lines how do you get out of the way let
them do what they have to do and still
get the shots you need I think it was
creating a safe place and an environment
to be able to make mistakes and say
we're not going to worry about this and
we're going to get right back up and
keep trying different things and having
that freedom and that confidence that
you could do that in a safe way that
allowed for creativity to flow Tony is
beyond creatively generous the music
that we have with the um scene at the
end of the movie which is the Vienna
Waltz was something that Tony he knocked
up he wrote it I mean I walk in and
Tony's Tony not only a great actor he
turns out he's bloody brilliant on the
piano as well you're like oh so
annoying again we're in independent film
we didn't have a lot of resources and
for him to just give us this music for
free was a big deal